our legend today is Tigran Petrosian
not the Tigran Petrosian that's playing
today
the one that's no longer playing there's
actually two of them this is the world
champion now Americans don't have a
reputation for being intelligent it's
well earned and I played in the Chicago
open several years ago and the current
Tigran Petrosian was playing about 26 50
feet a give or take and some of the
people like wow petrosian's playing I
know he played me more they think of the
world champion who had been dead for 10
years so yeah they were right that he
was in playing one of the directors
thought he was playing too so anyway
yeah if somebody's been dead for 10
years they're not playing in your
tournament all right now when I do the
the legends class I like to show a game
every decade so we can see how they
improved or disproved this is Petrosyan
versus Korchnoi coarsely still alive
amazing so you better get this on the
internet quick otherwise that saving
could be wrong so you better hurry up
this is in the Soviet championship under
18 in 1946 and this is well
Petrosian was known as a positional
player and as a defensive player and
that's pretty much true but he was a
strong grandmaster in a world champion
so if he had to sack all his pieces to
meet you he would and this game is
actually one of his great positional
efforts even though he was still a
teenager and this is against the Dutch
and Wow if you played this way today
against the Dutch you'll do very well
okay so of course should I played the
Dutch if you play Alex Marlar you might
face this move water also and well the
game was played in Leningrad so they
should have played the Leningrad Dutch
terrible but he played the Stonewall now
a lot of weaker players like the Dutch
and they like the Stonewall because they
play for checkmate and the night goes to
e4
and you push all your kingside pawns you
have a lot of fun the better you get at
chess the more you don't like the stone
wall because the ship on c8 gets very
mad at you because it's behind this wall
of pawns and that Bishop is going to be
bad for almost the whole game and then
when you get really good at chess then
you see the good and the bad you think
it's equal now in this position if this
game was played today
black would plum probably play Queen e7
because that prevents White's next move
and if this bishop is a terrible Bishop
conversely this Bishop is quite good and
has lots of possible squares to go to
controls a lot of squares white wants to
eliminate that Bishop one way to do so
is with Bishop f4 which we often see
however since white played b3 he played
the other way which is Bishop a3 of
course if blacks queen was on e7 that
would be quite a bad move because your
bishop would be hanging okay and they
traded now generally white wants to put
this knight on the side on the d3 square
where it controls a lot of squares and
f4 and E 5 in particular quite important
and Petrosian did that even though was
1946 he knew what he was doing Queen EEA
off of the Queen goes to the Kings side
for checkmating reasons and white played
queen c1 which defends all the dark
squares on the Queen side King side I
should say 94 91 91 might be a
funny-looking move to you but since I
already said Knight g3 was coming it
should be less funny g5 playing for the
attack although I don't think black has
a big attack with those pieces over
there 9 to d3 he gets a piece developed
and Knights a5 now some somebody in our
intelligent audience here please explain
to me why white played the knight on f2
e5 instead of the other
85 I'll accept two different answers
okay if you played the other night g4
could happen and what's the other reason
I drew like the night on g3 so that's
that's a better reason that I was going
to give as Groucho Marx would say yep uh
well actually very good hmm maybe if
this night goes to e5 you could argue e2
is weak but not this night so the
question actually was why did he play
this night and the reason which nobody
gave is to play my least favorite move
my least favorite move is f3 f3 taking
the night out I've been kicked out of
better places
what's tomorrow Friday yeah but not for
you you don't listen at home ok so we're
going to kick out this night which is a
pretty good night ok King to h8 he's
going to move his rook over here and
checkmate Wyatt not really but he's
going to try to f3 kicking the night out
and then e for now
efore might lose a pawn it might not
lose upon what's more important is white
wants to open the position because these
pieces can't move so all of white's
pieces are attacking and black's pieces
are trapped so for example if we trade
we already see the up file is open and
the White Queen can go here and we're
going to infiltrate so that's very
dangerous for black so Cork's really
didn't do that
he played Knight f7 trying to kick
White's night out then they traded
everything as was the style at the time
and black has what kind of
isolated and why he plays f4 and blacks
game is simply terrible because he's got
these pawns blocking his Bishop and
White has a protected pass pawn White
has control of the open file and because
of all of the trading it's very unlikely
that blacks going to checkmate white
there's no pieces to do it with ok the
immediate threat is the d5 pawn so he
played work to dat Queen c7 b6 and you
took on g5 again opening up the position
because black isn't well-developed
White's pieces are ready to go black
hasn't developed his pieces yet fact
we're pretty late in the game and these
pieces haven't moved yet it's like my
beginner class Bishop a6 finally getting
a piece out Knight f4 attacking the
Queen and black did something none of
you would ever do there like I would
never do it so I can't answer
black resigned so in this position I
like the way I was complaining black
didn't move his pieces then when he does
he resigns the reason is this Queen is
on this night then this Queen is
defending this Knight but your queen is
attacked so if you move your queen I'm
going to take your knight that's not
good and the absolute best black can do
although I doubt he could even do that
is get two pieces for is get a rook for
two pieces
that's if white doesn't play 96 and even
though black has a rook for two pieces
this is more lost than usual black has
three isolated pawns a weak King white
as the best night ever and pass pawn
this pawns falling but the worst
position I could imagine and 96 is
probably a threat okay so instead of
playing on he resigned a very nice
positional game for white blacks bishop
on CA never did anything
spawn structure became weak and
Petrosian opened the position before
black was ready for it to be opened that
game was played in the 40s now this game
is probably petrosian's most famous and
it's not a positional game at all
it's all tactics this was against Pok
Minh ok and Bachman wrote some famous
books and was a strong Grandmaster but
not really at the level of Petrosian
this was played in 1961 I skipped the
50s but I'll come back
ok positional and boring I'll wake you
up when it gets interesting
ok and now
Petrosian played very enterprising Lee
he played 'if I've very quickly before
black could play d6 and I think again if
grandmasters were playing today black
would either play d5 or d6 because this
seems to put a hole in the position here
where I can try to get my knight in
there or in here very weakening
okay so d6 which computer doesn't like
Knight d2 now we're ready to attack the
Queen Knight b3 attacking the C pawn and
he should play b6 but he played Knight
d4 Bishop f4 attacking the Queen and now
this is very funny after night digs b3
if somebody like no no Joe Garnier was
playing a blitz game you would play
eight eggs b3 and hit the clock so hard
that your flag would fall so you'd win
quicker than Petrosian but here
Petrosian play what I like to call
efficient Zhuge an in-between move he
didn't take the knight shocking
everybody what move to can white play
that doesn't take deny it
94 and the reason he played this is if
he takes Knight to d5 and now if you
play Knight C for my queen is c6 and I
can play b6 or b5m bishop
but if you play 94 here queen c6 is not
recommended due to Bishop takes Queen
the Queen has to go elsewhere and now
you take Queens not very good on b5 it
can get harassed more ways than one
a5 was played Bishop d6 Bishop f6 a
terrible square for the bishop it's not
defended I would never have played this
ship f6 yeah not a good move Queen f3
threatening the bishop but the bishops
defending the knight King g7 and now
Petrosian could have been equally famous
by playing it now but he waited a move
played rookie 4 and after Rick g8 he
played one of his most famous moves ever
which I'm sure you all knew before you
came to the lecture and I'm sure you all
know at home what did Petrosian play
he did play queen takes f6 which he
could have played on the previous move
now it's even better king takes bishop
check and actually well not today for
you people at home but today for us
there was a game played in Switzerland
and the famous Bill turn in there we are
the player with white decided to move
his King all the way up the board and he
did it safely somehow but but not here
yeah
so King g5 I'd like to escape with my
king but nope and and petrosian
fianchetto both of his bishops very nice
okay
so black is a queen up but that's a
pretty sorry queen and more importantly
that's a pretty sorry King and there's
no way to stop check me and there's more
than one checkmate so let's make a
random move we can play h4 jack and
Bishop f3 mate and if King here we can
play Bishop h3 mate if you don't like
that we can play 93 mate if you don't
like that we can play rook f4 mate if
you don't like that we can play g4 mate
so that that's not a good place for your
king and after Bishop g7 maid is
unavoidable and so black resigned so a
20 move miniature from the famous
positional player because his opponent's
king decided to walk up the board after
a very nice Queen sacrifice ok let's go
back to the 50s which we skipped this is
Petrosian white against an unknown
player and then he sort of played like I
do in one minute I guess he wasn't a big
fan of his opponent so this is very
common opening for amateur players
because all your pieces are out like
you're supposed to and now you can
checkmate your opponent that really
wasn't Petrosian style but since I've
never heard of his opponent maybe he
thought that was a good style to choose
Ben Simon all confused
Igor Chu ka who's at at 95 very
aggressive 98 now very instructive
moment he played
ship f4 one thing I tell my students
when you're trying to attack and
checkmate your opponent trading pieces
probably isn't going to help you succeed
so if we trade minor pieces here and
minor pieces here
maybe whites a little better but there's
no checkmate on the horizon so Bishop f4
keeps some pieces on the board
h4 it's like I'm playing one-minute
chess Knight f3 takes and Knight g5 so
Petrosian own for positional 's play is
just playing an all-out attacking game
and his opponent who isn't a strong
grandmaster is playing very passively
rook h3 now he makes a threat of the D
pawn because of the pin and it may or
may not work we have b4 but he played
King f1 no tricks no threats and even
though white is checkmate in black
Petrosian still takes time out to stop
Lex counter play that now goes back to
checkmating them man that's a lot a lot
of white pieces here attacking this g6
pawn very scary but now we know why he
played Bishop e8 Knight takes h7 typical
Petrosian style sacking all his pieces
takes takes check rook h6 threatening of
the night the only defense is Rick will
actually complain Rick f7 which would
feel the queen h5 so you took this queen
h5 and whites down a piece but there's
no defense to checkmate Bishop g6e 5
that's what the point of that was and
here after playing King g7 black
resigned
I'm sure White has checkmate in fact I
can see checkmate that's gonna play rook
takes rook
but I guess checkmate is preferable if I
can see the maid that means the players
can so here
Petrosian use all
his pieces to attack his opponents King
very unusual for him even though we saw
this in the pokémon game also
sacrificing for checkmate and he wasn't
known for that on the other hand most of
petrosian's well-known games were in
candidates matches World Championship
matches
Soviet Championships so when he's
playing lesser people he's going to just
take all their pieces and meet them okay
back to 70s back to the 70s so we did
the 40s the 60s and the 50s now we're
confused now there's a game he played in
the candidates against Fischer now many
super grandmasters and if you don't
believe me you come to the Sinquefield
Cup soon you can ask them the the
typical low rated chess player you see
in front of you is very impressed with
Fischer beading Larsen and timing off
6-0
strong grandmasters top 20 players in
the world and he beat them 6-0
very impressive however some super gems
I know are more impressed with this
match basically totally destroying
Petrosian Petrosian didn't get destroyed
Petrosian if he lost a match he'd lose
it by one point and usually he won the
matches and he was known for having a
lot of draws and a lot of boring
victories not the victory as we see
today and if you beat Petrosian you
didn't beat him by 4 or 5 points maybe
you beat him eight and a half seven and
a half if you were lucky which you
wouldn't be
however after taking Larsen and Taemin
off to school and picking him up at 3:30
who's a nice guy he then played
Petrosian and destroyed him and at one
point of the match I think he won four
games in a row now this was the one game
Petrosian won he gets to win a game
sometimes and this was in the match they
played in 71
Petrosian was white and a grünfeld and
you could see this line today even
though it's 34 years later 44 years
later
I was closed so in this position this is
still theory this little this all line
takes in fact when I played in the US
Championship in 2002 or 3 in in Seattle
this was the game Sara want Nakamura
which was a very long crazy draw Bishop
c4 not e2 so why does a pawn ahead
although this pawn seems like it's going
to fall Black has a past
a pawn which isn't very dangerous in
black why does this cluster of pawns on
the center now again if you think
Petrosian is going to beat somebody
especially of the caliber of Fisher who
was definitely the best player in the
world in 71 you'd think he just beat him
positionally in some slow boring game
but you'd be wrong
95 instead of taking on c5 which I guess
I'll take later this ship retreated
Fisher likes apply active Fisher wants
to play Knight d3 check he takes the
knight
Petrosian puts his knight in the center
Fischer wins his pawn back and we got
this opposite colored bishop position
now to correct the misnomers about
bishop opposite colors unless you're
playing me then think what you always
thought when you have bishop opposite
colors and there's no pieces on the
board it's relatively likely the game
may end in a draw when there's a lot of
pieces on the board especially what we
call heavies for your bughouse players
that's even more likely it'll be a win
because if you're attacking somebody
their bishop can't stop your Bishop
you're basically a bishop ahead and here
White's King is actually safer than
blacks King because we have this
potential on f7 and the G file is open
and I don't think we're going to Castle
queenside so white castled
and Fischer sort of has a problem with
his King played Queen a5 Queen c2 f4 I
don't like to move f4 although perhaps
black
was already in trouble I don't want to
give white the center open the center
when the black king is there c4 ignoring
f4 and my favorite move of the game
we'll see if the if the class can figure
it out this is second I have to call
Vegas and bet against you guys it's 10
to 1 against you I just got the odds
what did why play
anyone I place the bet no me I'm going
to win the bet it's great what's that
Queenie for too aggressive look Queenie
for is a good one
your move has the right spirit because
you didn't take the point on III very
good
he played c5 wait a minute
my bet didn't get put dit why not I
can't believe it Vega said the vet
doesn't count
unbelievable now with c5 our pawns are
looking good and we're getting the
diagonal open for our Bishop ignoring
the pawn on e3
well white white wants the center open
since blacks King is on ei black would
like to trade Queens because then if the
Kings I needed doesn't care I played
Queen d2 do you think white traded
Queens now he played your move Queen 1/4
I play Queenie for Queen Shaq and then
Rick do you want I play Queen e4 yeah
okay rook to d1 attacking the Queen d6
yeah this King is getting a little scary
now Queen h5 f 4 I really like f4
because it looks like blacks threatening
e 2 because blacks threatening e 2 you I
have an answer
then I would play rook takes Queen
ah you're sneaky e - I have to take your
queen no and you play for tricks you
know what's going on here this looks
like the game this looks better for
black than the game
but similar this is actually looks
similar to the game he actually wanted
to rub he did win a rook but he later
yeah play rook do you want now Bishop c4
Queen up Queen f4 yeah it's probably
better than what he did probably saw it
rejected it well I didn't see Bishop age
too sneaky that'd be good in one minute
okay well I should let's see what the
computer says I don't have to turn the
computer on what control who three
thanks that's very helpful so II - oh
man it plays pawn takes equals Knight
check which is very funny yeah it makes
a knight it says that it says after
making a queen d6 White's plus a million
Wow it says the black is incredibly lost
like +10 wow I thought like White's
better because blacks King is funny but
I wouldn't said plus ten then like plus
eight that's still a terrible yeah so it
looks like both players saw that now
what do I do
like quit quit the lecture well you said
you think that means you know right
although yeah it would have been funnier
if you take it a night for the class
yeah it doesn't look good for black okay
so he played Queen e2 d6 and now you
play deaf
or e2 has suggested takes takes and even
though black is up in exchange these
aren't so good over here and these are
really good
so my bishop is probably better than
either one of your rooks and my Center
pawns are definitely better than your
pawns Queen takes e5 Rick f1 threatening
f7 never play f6 Queen b3 threatening
Queen f7 checkmate takes threatening
rook takes f6 check yeah and this is my
favorite move of the game even though I
already said that it's the last move I
would think of that's why I like it so
we got three legal moves right rook f2
King f1 king h1 those are the three
legal moves which looks the stupidest
that's the one you played I guess work
f2 is pretty stupid look he ran his King
into the corner normally you get maybe
when you do that but if the Queen goes
to the back rank we play rook f1 and
then we play rook f6 yeah that's not
good by the way many of you know in the
Fischer Spassky mansion 72 there was a
game where Fischer didn't move one of
his rocks right you guys memorized that
game yeah I don't think I don't think it
would either one of those works this
game did he why move your rook swear you
won't have to this looks like a Murphy
game black moved his king and queen
every move and did move his rugs
okay and your Fischer resigned so it's
funny most of petrosian's games in the
lecture thus far sacrifice play crazy
but usually it's more Fischer style
okay and then again from the 80s now as
all of you now I was in Moscow 1984 like
most Americans when I was 14 and I had a
sport visa and when I got to the the
border in Moscow
golf the plane the guy said sport what
sport and I said chess and then we
waited in line for quite a while then
eventually we got to where we were going
the sport hotel and I was in a seminar
for three weeks and we had every Soviet
chess player at the time teach us
Petrosian was scheduled to teach us but
he was sick and he died maybe long can
the internet will tell you but yeah he
died maybe the year later but this was
in 84 and another funny story because I
was hilarious there's a chess player in
Michigan named Greg Bailey who's
actually been to our chess club several
times class a player occasionally he's
an expert not too often and he named his
son Tigran after G grandpa Trojan like
you're going to do and one day I saw him
in the 80s and I was like yeah you know
it's too bad
Petrosian he said what so I actually
told him about a year later he just
didn't know that Petrosian died doin if
Internet then so we didn't know what's
going on yeah and I was one way to tell
him so he must have liked petrosian's
play because now in case my comer
watches this video we better flip the
board now I was reading a new in chess
today at the chess club and there was an
article by Yann Tim on who's white of
this game about Miguel Knight Orff and
he was like 9 or F was a thousand years
older than me but we had good times
together gay the drinking buddies and
they played seven times in tournaments
which is amazing because when I ork must
have been in his 60s and 70s and Tim was
in his 20s I guess what's they repaired
a lot I never played either one of them
if I never been nine or here's the game
Tim on petrol C on from the 80s so
Petrosian was ending his career and
was was just beginning and their ratings
were about the same and again Petrosian
was known for boring put you to sleep
you know steal your wallet while you're
asleep but man he he torts him on come
on up
Timlin likes to play sort of wild and
crazy chess so some of his losses are
pretty bad and his wins are fantastic
but this is one of his losses
okay petrosian's black and he played the
Queen's game but accepted good thing
might come worse not here he would say
why is black giving away the center and
they transpose to a Slav this is
actually one of my favorite tricks a lot
of books have opening traps that never
happen this is actually happened in
Grandmaster games in the 50s and 60s and
early 70s and then they were like hey we
got to stop doing this so after it was
showed in a lot of books people stopped
wandering this way in this position in
the 70s and 80s everybody played Bishop
f5 here
now they play everything Bishop f5 still
the most common Petrosian would
occasionally play Bishop to g4 which in
the 80s and 90s was played by Nicholas
the Yugoslavian Grandmaster bosnian
grandmaster and after 95 attacking the
bishop the bishop moves away and y can
play g3 or f3 the most aggressive
exciting is f3 that's what - ma would
always do and whites trying to build a
big Center Knight F to d7 trying to
trade off this beautiful night and now
that move e5 and probably if you go into
a chest database you'll find maybe 2000
games in this position and it may be a
hundred and fifty of them white
blundered here and they don't blunder
anymore at the Grandmaster level but
most of you aren't grandmasters so you
might blender here and some of you are
probably confused why white why black
played night FG 7 and 7 night BD 7 now
you're going to find out why after the
obvious move D takes e5 the game is over
Queen h4 put it in H checking the king
and attacking the knight I hate when
that happens
but it's happened to several people okay
and if we play Knight B to d7 then we're
not going to jump over other night
okay so we take with it we take with a
knight not okay and blacks a pawn down
but black has a nice Bishop other Bishop
is out Knights threatening the pawn
White has doubled pawns White's pawns on
a four for some reason White's bishops
are terrible
okay so black has compensation for upon
F for defending his pawn Bishop b4 again
Petrosian was known for boring
positional play but now he's sacrificing
a pawn with black and trying to run over
his opponent which he did Queen c2 Queen
e7 e for a pretty risky move because
black King Castle either way and White
has a lot of space in front of his King
g5 and this actually is a positional
move more than a tactical move and it's
very well known to French players I
don't mean people from France I mean
people who play the French defense
because your F pawn is defending ee5 g5
bishop now again if the if the if this
gets open that's not good for white
white can't Castle black and castle
either way blacks bishops are both out
White's bishops haven't moved so even
though black is a pawn down he's really
attacking White's King white playing
Bishop e2 and some get my King out of
there takes on F for now the e5 pawn is
hanging ecigs
trying to lose the pawn in a better way
than laying the night go to g5 Queen
check and this is probably what's him on
missed I I would Castle here and lose
but at least I would Castle II 6 now
you're not going to Castle and again
this had to be calculated Tim on play
King F 1 but if you play
and take the night I don't know where my
king goes I think I can go anywhere I'd
probably go to da I'm not sure why and
then I don't know I I don't like this
because G to check is winning this
doesn't look like fun looks like fun for
black however having said that I would
have done that because I may be losing
by MUP a piece the way Tim on plate is
loosely and he's not up a piece I don't
agree with any of that so you play King
f1 I don't like that okay Bishop takes
check takes and now in a very strange
material equanimity black is up material
and and White's got all this going on
why should we have ensure not black
terrible Queen f2 now remember as I've
taught all of you when you're up
material you trade Queens right no I've
never taught anybody any of that that's
what some stupid book you read taught
you okay you trade Queens because your
king is in trouble White's King is in
trouble why it's Kings on f1 and the
rook on h1 is trapped so white wants to
trade Queens black is like Oh black and
Castle either way probably Queen side
and White's King I'm going to slam them
so did petrosian trade Queens now now
Queen back to e7 now tim-mah now
followed my advice which I wouldn't have
followed you can be losing and down upon
or you can be losing and now down upon
so he chose my advice which is losing in
that down upon I back away from my
advice now because he opened up the
floodgates to his king by e5 and Bishop
takes f4 he's opening up the F file and
there's a black rook that's going to go
there that's not going to be good so I
know what that was all about see the
reason he played e5 was if he takes the
pawn
now I can play e5 and rook f8 you resign
so yeah okay so rook f8 now black is
threatening Knight d3 and Knight g6 and
black is up upon what I like about Queen
e7 which I didn't mention earlier was it
protects the bishop
so imagine you just move your queen to
some random square and the guy starts
attacking all of your pieces don't you
hate when that happens
let Bishop c3 win anyway but Queen e7
petrosian's like you're not attacking my
bishop is defended everything's defended
ok so then yeah Rick d1 stopping black
from castling Bishop c5 and it's harsh
getting harsh around here exactly
somebody said why is it white resigning
wow that's amazing they don't know
what's going on here now I'm just glad
persons in California alright and then
white did what none of you ever do
resigned if you didn't resign what would
you do here you could move your queen
and then I would probably play Knight g6
and then I would play e5 and men sure
should have resigned in this position
your Queens and so careful careful
it's still not that bad Knight d6 check
yeah now you know you got some problems
over here you have problems when you
walked into class now you got chest
problems it's different so here if we if
you think of the games of Petrosian I
mean he was known as a boring positional
player but look at these games I just
showed you okay I didn't show you those
ad move wins he had where you couldn't
do anything because you know you don't
want see that you want to see this and
there's a lot of examples of this and
it's well known and the Soviet hierarchy
that Petrosian was a great blitz player
because all those tricks that you plan
your friends you
can play those on him yeah so he stopped
everything you could do and you either
lose on time or you'd go crazy and lose
she's a great tournament player great
blitz player and the World Championship
cycle was made for Petrosian game in
those days and I guess now you had to
win a match
imagine if the World Championship was
like the Sinquefield Cup you had the 10
best players in the world play like a
round-robin or double round-robin
petrosian's not going to be the world
champion ever but if it's a match
between two people and you have to win a
game then petrosian's your man so he was
like draw draw draw a normal champion
I'm the best and for a tournament for
tournament player he didn't win a lot of
tournaments and now I'll tell you my
favorite Petrosian story which probably
isn't true that's why it's my favorite
probably it's apocryphal but you never
know as you all know the Soviet Union
had good Olympiad teams possibly the six
players they had were the six best
players in the world that would be a
good Olympic team at one Olympics they
were meeting who's on our Olympic team
and they voted Bava Knicks
even though Bob Vinick was the world
champion because they had Petrosian they
had tall they had Chara's
they had smiie Slav and those were their
weak players yeah so they're having like
six crew okay Bob the Knicks out like
all right Bob next world champion all
right so in a minute he was like gold
medal on board one well when Bob when it
was out and they put Petrosian in there
was a gold medal for you for some reason
I don't know why when he played in
tournaments
it was draw draw draw draw win win win
third place okay when he played in the
Olympiad it was win win win win when I
don't have no happen in the Olympiad
Petrosian won every game so he's like
gold gold gold go and the Olympiad board
one board - every time 12 wins 2 draws
so Petrosian love the Olympiad I don't
know why maybe like I kicked me off the
team I'm the world champion so I better
play good the Olympiad man that was some
good Olympic teams five world champions
and Cara's and course
why not throw him into and then some
weak players like opera Bach and Kotov
as strong Olympic team bola Slav ski
bought Stein and some good limping team
okay now they broke all those countries
up and Armenia still wins every Olympiad
hard to understand alright so that was
the great Tigran Petrosian if you see
him in a tournament it's not him it's
the other guy you can call him the other
guy also chi grande Petrosian but slight
difference